infamous cult leader and murderer
Charles Manson died of natural causes on
Sunday and many used his death to
compare him to some of the worst men who
ever lived on earth but not Newsweek
they thought it was appropriate to
compare Manson to yes
Oh President Trump the struggling
publication I like to call it Newsweek
WEA k ran a story with the headline
quote how murderer Charles Manson and
Donald Trump used language to gain
followers we should note that Newsweek
has since changed the headline to remove
the reference to the president isn't
that nice the New York Times also ran a
strange opinion piece that seemed to try
to time Manson to the summit President
Trump supporters making the case that
Manson was inspired by right-wing causes
rather than the far-left counterculture
good luck with that joining us now for
reaction Howie Kurtz the host of Fox
News's media buzz which I love and I
watch every Sunday at 11:00 a.m. Howie
let's talk about this Newsweek thing I
mean now that I've heard a lot of
wackiness going after Trump but this
rates way up there it has its own
special yeah it's just despicable and it
follows this sort of lunatic trend of
comparing Donald Trump to the worst
villains in human history you know but
Hitler has already been done well
Charles Manson just died right yeah and
so you know it's this utterly illogical
argument about well both Manson and
Trump use emotional language to appeal
to their alienate supporters so it's
okay to compare the president to a mass
murderer no I mean III think the left
the left always tends to go just a
little bit too far and then they go a
little bit farther and a little farther
but this is like a level of we call it
Trump derangement syndrome but it's it's
psychosis so so when they have some kind
of sort of legitimate right a beef with
him on substance or policy it's kind of
diminished I think because they're so
far overboard on these comparisons that
they just look no matter the guy could
cure lung cancer tomorrow and they'd say
oh he could have done it two years ago
and he didn't do it so that's in that
for that reason I think this is this is
nuts let's go to Charlie Rose I've known
Charlie Rose since I don't know in 1995
I think the first time I went on his
show and it's just on a show a couple of
weeks ago for my book billionaire at the
Cades had a great interview this is a
this is a big figure in the media
following a lot of other big figures
some in our own network CBS PBS
Bloomberg CBS is kandan what's going on
well it took about 24 hours from that
well-documented Washington Post piece to
be published before CBS and he's a
franchisee their morning show 60 minutes
yeah as well as PBS so but the network's
really had no choice Laura I mean the
devastating details in this post piece
about how he would lure women out to his
estate on Long Island and either come on
to them or grope them or whatever and
some of them were looking for jobs some
of them were fairly young women really
left them no choice and the fact is he's
a charismatic guy but he blew up his own
career as any network not been touched
by this I guess touches where I
shouldn't use but as any network not
been rocked by some level of this type
of sexual harassment allegation not just
New York Times this has been a White
House correspondent glanced over
allegations so it is you know it's
Halperin yeah it started in Hollywood
and Silicon Valley our own business it
really is quite a cultural moment and
now Charlie Rose one of its biggest
people to fall we're saying earlier that
it will be a shame however if this
changes the way people can have any
interaction in the workplace look I know
I ought to know a lot of people friends
of mine from college and law school who
met each other in the workplace I mean
how many times you so well I met
somebody and they became friends that we
started dating right and now like a
quarter of young people we did this poll
last night a quarter of young people
according to this new YouGov poll say
that if someone asks another person out
and they're not romantically involved
that that can be sexual harassment just
by asking for a day yeah but asking for
a minute so now it's talk about lunacy
then you couldn't we nor you can ever
have human reactions like how do you
ever ask someone out in the work contest
I guess you never can even in this over
that's kind of little I mean not every
allegation is correct either some are
devastatingly true right sometimes
people just late I guess they want to
date somebody and they say would you
want to go out I guess you can't do that
even Charlie Rose had a kind of pathetic
at that time I rose
yes but but let's make distinctions
because in this hothouse environment Oh
another case the section was kind of
between a grope of somebody was a little
too aggressive on a date and somebody
who was accused of rape sexual assault I
mean it's not all the same yeah just
quickly Donna Brazile I want to play the
sound bite really quickly for me this
was earlier tonight on MSNBC let's watch
my personal view is that it was not a
legitimate election it doesn't count
Chris remember I'm the campaign manager
of Al Gore in 2000 and where as you well
know the Supreme Court decided this this
election will always have an asterisk by
and that's why I think Donald Trump
should take as president to clean up our
system so that no more foreign
governments of no foreign meddling with
a current or future this is a change of
heart really quickly brought Donna
Brazile trying to get in the back of
that good grace of the dancy what's
going on so she sells books by saying
the primaries were rigged for Hillary
now she is sold a lot of books and she
wants to make and kiss and make up with
the Democratic Party so the whole
election is rid of that do you have a
great Thanksgiving thank you too